Cómo se espera que Carlos tercero
enfrente este rol de ser el reino del
Reino Unido no Qué diferencias tiene que
aplicar respecto a su madre para que su
imagen esté a la altura de los tiempos
Pues realmente el carisma y el cariño
que los ingleses y todos los miembros de
la mancomunidad le tienen a Su Majestad
no se hereda Carlos tendrá también que
llegar a ganarse un sitial ha buscado
durante muchísimos años como un príncipe
activista
acceder precisamente al cariño de las
personas a través de su actividad en
torno al medio ambiente pero es muy
difícil para muchos que todavía se
acuerdan y que guardan un grato recuerdo
de la primera esposa del Rey Carlos III
que recientemente la semana anterior se
cumplieron 25 años de su fallecimiento y
que también guardan cierto resentimiento
hacia quien es o ha sido el amor de la
vida del Rey Carlos III quien
inicialmente este año la reina manifestó
que no sería no continuaría como Duquesa
de cornuales sino como reina consorte la
reina Camila y precisamente veíamos en
imágenes la llegada tanto de la reinada
con suerte de Camila como del Rey Carlos
III en este momento la reina consorte de
hecho está saliendo del avión que los
transportó desde Aberdeen hasta Londres
Hernán yo le quiero preguntar algo y es
usted mencionó a la primera ministra
listros y su breve pero impactante
discurso en el que resaltaba la figura
de la reina y de la monarca como la
piedra de la Democracia británica sin
embargo Liz trash tiene una historia
anti monárquica Y es que antes de asumir
el Downey Street se conocieron videos de
su juventud en la que en los que ella
criticó a la monarquía Cómo entender
esta figura de una primera ministra que
en su momento se declaró antimonarca que
paradójicamente es la última primera
ministra que le tocó a la Reina Isabel y
con un dato Y es que periodistas de
edgardian publicaron una imagen o un
acercamiento a una imagen del encuentro
entre la Reina Isabel y esta misma
semana en el que se leía una frase en
latín donde decía que nadie que juzgue a
la monarquía pasará en vano se pueden
entender esto como un mensaje simbólico
como los que le gustaba la reina sí
efectivamente pero también tenemos el
rey
la reina nunca muere o el Rey nunca
muere es una monarquía con más de 900
años más de 40 Reyes han sido coronados
donde será Coronado el próximo año
Carlos III y la primera ministra en este
caso como jefa del gobierno pues tiene
que respetar la tradición que aunque
tenga ella los votos de todas maneras
hace parte de un partido tradicionalista
en el cual ha habido pues la mayoría de
los primeros ministros que
transcurrieron en el de estos 70 años
del reinado de Isabel segunda y para
centrarnos en la figura del nuevo
monarca de Carlos III antes de que
falleciera Isabel II y él la tomara ya
fuera digamos el rey oficialmente del
Reino Unido se especulaba con el hecho
de que pudiera abdicar en favor de su
hijo el príncipe William y de hecho
mucha prensa se ha referido al nuevo rey
como un príncipe profesional que ASUME
al final el trono con 73 años de edad
porque cree que no ha abdicado a favor
de su hijo y que ha asumido el encargo
de ese Rey efectivamente por la misma
condición que coherencia en ese tema de
la tradición en el trono y de asumir la
responsabilidad que le deja la Reina
Isabel hace un poco más de 10 años
empezó un movimiento europeo en el cual
algunos de Los Monarcas abdicaron por
ejemplo la prima de la Reina Isabel la
hoy en día princesa Beatriz de los
Países Bajos para dar paso a los que
estaban en turno Igualmente ocurrió en
España sin embargo nunca se pensó que la
reina abdicara en favor de su de su hijo
sino siempre se pensó eventualmente que
sería en su nieto lógicamente Este es un
príncipe como bien lo dices Rosa un
príncipe profesional que llega próximo a
cumplir los 74 años en el mes de
noviembre y el cual Pues precisamente
debido a la vitalidad que tiene tanto
por línea materna como por línea paterna
su padre alcanzó casi a frizar el siglo
permanecerá en el trono lo único es que
el príncipe William que aún no es
príncipe de gales tendrá que esperar la
decisión de su padre para ser proclamado
como príncipe de gales y Coronado como
tal para eventualmente en ese momento y
pensando en que los hijos del príncipe
William vayan creciendo un poco más
entonces Carlos decida si abdica o
pertenece en el trono hasta el final de
sus días Gracias Hernán y yo le tengo
una pregunta muy rápida que le pido que
la responda muy brevemente y es para que
el príncipe William sea Coronado como el
príncipe de gales El rey ya tiene que
estar Coronado como tal No
necesariamente tiene que estar Coronado
sin embargo como todos son actos
protocolarios que dependen de lo que
está escrito por la casa real muy
seguramente será el próximo año Eso sí
después de la coronación la el
recibimiento de la corona de William y
de su esposa como príncipes de gales que
por extensión entonces a la nueva
Duquesa de conwales que es Kate
middleton le corresponderá también
asumir ese título Hernán olano miembro
de la asociación de amigos del castillo
de Windsor Gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en Francia y Gracias Rosa
también por acompañarnos con nuestro